While we're on the topic of
problems that are easy or hard for
optimizers to solve, let's talk for
a moment about a particular class of
problems that are indeed the most easy
for these types of algorithms to solve.
And those are called convex problems.
Here's the formal definition
of a convex function.
I'm going to read it
to you from Wikipedia.
And then I'll show you what it
means on these graphs here.
A real valued function f
of x defined on an interval
is called convex if
the line segment between
any two points on the graph of
the function lies above the graph.
A lot of words there.
Let me show you what
that means more easily.
First step, choose two points and
draw a line between them.
Now, for each of these lines, if
the line is above the graph, everywhere
between those two points, then the
function is convex between those points.
So for this function, yes,
it's convex because the line
is above the graph everywhere.
In fact, any two points you chose on
this graph, we'll have that property.
So this function is convex everywhere,
at least where we're looking at.
Here, notice that this part of
the graph lies above the line.
So this is non convex.
Similarly, this one,
we've got this region here
that lies above the line, so
this one is also non convex.
And this one is of course convex.
So a couple things to observe here,
some properties that emerged.
One is in order for
the function to be convex,
it has to have only one local minima.
And in other words,
that local minima is the global minima.
This one fails for that reason.
We also can't have any flat regions
that essentially don't
have any slope downward.
Now, if the function you're trying
to find a minima for is convex,
then these algorithms will find
the minima quickly and easily.
But again, there are algorithms
that can still find the minima for
more complicated examples like these.
But they require a little
bit of randomness and
they aren't necessarily guaranteed
to find the global minima.
So far, we've been looking at functions
that just have one dimension in x.
So for instance,
the parabola that we looked at.
It’s just as easy for these optimizers
to work in multiple dimensions.
Here’s an example of a function
that has two dimensions in x.
It still has its y result.
But the minimizers can solve these
problems with gradient descent
just as easily.
So instead of just one dimension,
we can have one,
two, three, four, as many as we’d like.